[Music]
let me tell you something
a driver on picnic on
car picked the drive some mrs. kebab
between man and machines of mr. Kumar
between man
[Music]
who are you
do you speak told her you
[Music]
what's your name
[Applause]
you got people out there we'll need you
this is why you're here be
and opie music can help you say what
you're feeling try this hey everybody
its charlie we got a new Iron Giant
trailer to break down that is the
bumblebee movie they're going more Iron
Giant route if you guys remember the
origins of the original transformers
live-action film Steven Spielberg was
gonna direct they were gonna do it more
like The Iron Giant or et like a boy in
his car but then it got turned into this
big Michael Bay thing so he's left the
franchise this movie doesn't have
anything to do with Michael Bay he's not
directing it so they've gone smaller
instead of going bigger like we just did
Unicron now we're back to girl and her
car set during the 80s so you probably
notice that these are all the gen 1
versions of the characters that's why he
turns into a beetle instead of a Camaro
that's why Starscream looks like classic
Starscream so welcome back we haven't
seen him in a while this kind of seems
like it's gonna be the future of the
franchise this type of movie just like a
little bit smaller a little more
intimate there was like another big
transformers movie that was supposed to
happen in the next couple of years they
took that off the schedule so it seems
like in the wake of Michael Bay leaving
the franchise paramount and Hasbro have
gone back to the drawing board which if
you're a fan of transformers at all I
feel like that's a really good thing but
if you're wondering about other
transformers and Decepticons popping up
during this because it does seem like a
smaller film they have confirmed that
Optimus Prime is gonna show up probably
at the end of the film because she finds
bumblebee and it seems like the whole
plot is them helping each other out ET
style like them running from the
government like John Cena's character in
the military and also running from the
Decepticons and Starscream until
bumblebee is able to contact the other
Autobots Allah Optimus Prime but they
also confirmed that there's a Decepticon
that's gonna turn into a 1971 Plymouth
GTX bear Kate is coming back there's no
sign of Megatron so I'm assuming that
right now Starscream is the biggest
Decepticon villain that's in the film
but we might see others but I just I
love the idea that they're doing classic
80s it's set during 1987 which is
actually the year after the original
animated Transformers movie was released
so I'm also wondering if they're doing
all these classic
former's designs if they're going to
bring back some of the classic music
like the touch or any of the other 80s
stuff like lions heavy-metal cover of
the Transformers theme maybe over the
credits usually that's where they put
stuff like that
[Music]
[Applause]
but obviously they have the joke about
rickrolling the thing about that you
have to remember this is the 80s so Rick
Astley hasn't become ironic yet so
that's why she has the smile on her face
look oh hey this is cool new band I
found out about his name's Rick Astley
there's the joke about the Beehive
underneath the wheel well when she finds
him so that's probably how he gets his
name bumble bee so I'm wondering if they
actually do give that to him during this
movie because if you're going on
original continuity he would have been
called bumble bee back on Cybertron but
that doesn't really make sense because
the Autobots are an alien race so why
would they call themselves something
from Earth but don't let that trap you
in a logic loop but they do go with the
bumblebee motif because like his face
shield here when it goes down actually
makes him look kind of like a bumblebee
but from the way she finds him it looks
like they either had just crash-landed
on earth or there was some big battle
with the Decepticons because it looks
like bumblebee has PTSD when she first
wheels him into her garage but it's hard
to tell how long he's been baking in the
Sun inside this trash heap because it's
been long enough for a bee hive to be
created so it seems like it's been a
while the only real synopsis for the
movie is that he just gone to this town
to hide out they don't say where he came
from how long he's been here in where
the other Autobots and Decepticons are
but really the only reason for
Starscream to want to chase him down is
to either find information that he has
on the location of something if he's
looking for Energon if he's looking for
the location of the Autobot ship maybe
he's trying to track down Megatron
there's just probably something that
bumblebee has that he wants and
obviously the military is pretty
self-explanatory john cena learns about
a robot that can change into other
things of course he's gonna want to take
it down so that's really where you get
to the iron giant ET of it also of
course it makes sense that steven
spielberg has his hands in some of this
from the background
[Music]
but let me know what you think about
this Transformers movie knowing that
Michael Bay isn't really involved with
it I think he still gets a producer
credit because he was involved in
creating the franchise but I don't think
that he did any actual work on this I
think they're trying to give it a sense
of heart that the Transformers movies
have not had in a long long time if they
ever had it but the person that directed
this also did Kubo in the two strings so
it does let you know the Paramount and
Hasbro really do care about getting
really creative good storytellers in
this not just like the big flashy
directors like Michael Bay but the
really cool news is that we actually
have a Spider Man spider verse trailer
dropping tomorrow and I also think
there's some other stuff How to Train
Your Dragon 3 might also be dropping a
trailer hopefully my voice is a little
bit better I've been sick the last
couple of days but while you wait for
everything click here for the new Lego 2
trailer and click here for that new
ant-man the wasp trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]